Україна є одним з лідерів в Європі
по відсотковому приросту електромобілів.
Це щось нове, це щось таке,
що може справді змінити наше життя на краще.
Мене звати Назар Шимоне-Давида.
Я один із трьох співзасновників компанії «Go To-U».
Наша компанія розробляє платформу,
яка об'єднує власників електромобілів і бізнеси,
які встановлюють зарядні пристрої у своїх локаціях.
Чим зручніше вам користуватися електромобілем,
чим більш розвинена інфраструктура,
тим більше ви, як кінцевий споживач, вмотивовані
перейти на більш дешевий та зручний вид транспорту.
Я, Благовісний Стефан, співзасновник компанії «ТОКА».
Наша компанія займається розробкою електрочарджерів
та розбудовою власної мережі автозаправних комплексів.
Місія нашої компанії — зробити користування електромобілем
таким же зручним, як і звичайним авто.
У 2014 році ми придбали перші електромобілі Nissan Leaf.
І зіткнулися з тією обставиною,
що немає можливості їх заряджати по місту.
Ми розуміли, що першим завданням для нас — це буде знайти
потенційно цікаві і зручні для клієнтів місця для зарядки.
І почали поступово встановлювати зарядні пристрої.
Вони були безкоштовні, оскільки в нас не було програми,
яка б могла їх монетизувати.
І після цього ми почали, по-перше, створювати власний софт,
по-друге — створювати власні зарядні пристрої.
Сьогодні в нас понад 15 тисяч клієнтів.
Понад 460 чарджін-поінтів [пунктів для зарядження],
переважна більшість — це зарядки змінного струму.
Ми перебуваємо в нашому центральному офісі,
тут у нас розташоване наше виробництво.
Це наша команда, яка збирає, власне, зарядні пристрої.
Конкурентною перевагою наших станцій є те, що вони
мають можливість статично ділити потужність, яку ми маємо.
А також динамічно її розподіляти між усіма станціями.
Олег — це наш головний інженер.
Він з нами з 2016 року.
Зараз перед вами діюча зарядна станція на два порти
для заряджання двох електромобілів одночасно.
Щоб станція була універсальна,
[вона має] два конектори під різні типи автомобілів.
Автомати захисту та комутуюча система.
Це європейські виробники, які дуже-дуже надійні.
А всі контролери та управління — українського виробництва.
Smart grid solution — це той принцип,
який ми використовуємо на всіх наших зарядних пристроях,
коли ти маєш можливість ділити потужність
між портами, з об’єктом живлення.
Тобто ідея була дуже проста —
це використовувати вільну потужність, надпотужність,
яку, наприклад, використовує багатоповерховий дім,
для того, щоб заряджати електромобілі на парковці.
Для цього необхідно забирати вільну потужність
і ефективно надавати її електромобілям.
Для того, щоб зарядити автомобіль,
необхідно мати застосунок на мобільному телефоні.
Завантажити його та зареєструватися.
Надалі, без застосунку, ви можете користуватися карткою.
Принцип зарядки максимально простий.
Відмикаємо порт.
Вставляємо конектор.
На кожному порті є QR-код, ми просто скануємо його в додатку,
і він автоматично направляє на процес зарядки.
І вмикаємо кнопку «Підключитись».
Швидкість зарядки залежить від двох факторів:
по-перше — яка можливість у зарядного пристрою
(наразі ця зарядна станція може видавати 22 кВт на один порт)
і по-друге — це можливість вашого автомобіля.
Коли ми починали, інфраструктури взагалі не було.
Було декілька стацій, які були встановлені.
У 2014 році було, приблизно, 180 електромобілів,
зареєстрованих в Україні.
Перше — це було цікаво, це було щось нове.
Якщо ти заряджаєш у себе вдома,
то для тебе це приблизно 16 гривень на 100 кілометрів.
Навіть якщо ти заряджаєшся, наприклад, у нас у мережі,
то ти маєш [на] 100 кілометрів приблизно 80 гривень.
Різниця велика.
Навіть майже вдвічі різниця з газом.
З’явилися фаст-чарджери [пристрої для швидкого зарядження],
яких взагалі не було в 2014 році.
Понад три тисячі зарядних станцій сьогодні на ринку.
Приблизно 30+ тисяч клієнтів.
З’явилося розуміння, що це вже next level
[наступний рівень] розвитку автомобілів.
Упродовж одного року експлуатації автомобіль
з двигуном внутрішнього згоряння викидає
приблизно одну тонну шкідливих речовин в повітря,
яким ми постійно дихаємо на наших вулицях.
А електромобіль взагалі нічого не викидає.
Тобто чистота повітря, якщо всі пересядуть на електромобілі,
буде така сама, як всі їздили би на велосипедах,
тому що викидів, як таких, взагалі немає.
Мій особистий досвід взагалі з електромобілями
почався ще навіть до «Тесли».
Свого часу, коли я жив в Америці,
я працював у дилерській «Тойоти».
І ще у далекому 2007 році я вперше
зрозумів, що таке електромобіль.
У першу чергу — це тихість ходу,
коли ви їдете в електромобілі.
Дуже легко ним керувати і найцікавіше — це динаміка
прискорення, тобто ця динаміка є моментальна.
У такому автомобілі набагато комфортніше
і набагато легше його експлуатувати, обслуговувати.
Тобто фактично він обслуговування, як такого, не потребує.
У нас в команді є, в першу чергу, три рівноправні
співзасновники — це я, Лєна і Люба.
Ми троє почали цю компанію і зараз уже
близько 20 людей працює на постійній основі з «Go To-U».
Оскільки ми самі не могли фінансувати розвиток
інфраструктури в Україні, зі зрозумілих причин,
тоді ми придумали так звану партнерську програму,
коли ми пропонували бізнесам купувати
зарядні станції і їх встановлювати.
А ми до них приводили клієнтів,
які використовували ті електромобілі.
Тобто нашими партнерами можуть стати фактично
будь-які бізнеси, в яких є свої паркомісця.
Ми їм пропонуємо якісний інструмент
контролю їхньої зарядної станції.
Для нашого кінцевого користувача ми забезпечуємо зручний
користувацький досвід завдяки мобільному застосунку.
І, найважливіше, наш користувач,
коли користується нашим сервісом,
отримує стовідсоткову гарантію, що зарядка
буде доступна тільки для нього, коли він до неї приїде.
Тому що резервація зарядної станції —
це фактично основа нашої технології.
Коли людина приїжджає, зарядна станція доступна тільки неї.
І наша платформа фактично складається з таких двох частин:
це мобільний застосунок для кінцевого користувача
і платформа, якою користується власне бізнес
для управління всім процесом зарядної станції.
Отже, ми зарезервували зарядну станцію, приїхали вчасно,
включилися в зарядку, включили зарядну станцію.
Бачу, скільки часу в мене залишилося,
на скільки кВт я вже зарядила автомобіль.
Також можу зробити селфі чек-ін,
щоб тим самим популяризувати місце,
яке дало мені можливість заряджатись під час того,
як я, наприклад, проводжу обід з діловими партнерами.
Роблю селфі чек-ін.
Наша мета, у першу чергу, —
це стати глобальною платформою.
І зараз ми вже представлені в багатьох країнах,
починаючи з України, Польщі, Португалії, Таїланду.
Зараз починаємо виходити на ринок Сполучених Штатів.
Наша мета — щоб наш застосунок
використовували в кожній країні.
Тобто ми маємо стати глобальним лідером і глобальною
платформою для інфраструктури зарядних станцій.
Це не є просто бізнес як для заробляння суто грошей.
Для нас, у першу чергу, гроші як такі — це просто інструмент,
щоб далі розвиватися, далі щось робити,
далі приносити якусь користь
суспільству, покращувати світ, напевно.
Як це банально не було би сказано,
але ми намагаємось робити цей світ кращим.